la russie met fin à ces exercices
militaires en crimée chez le ministre
russe de la défense l'a annoncé dans la
journée
les exercices menés selon moscou pour
faire face aux activités menaçantes de
l'otan dans la région
ils ont été perçus comme une escalade
par washington et ont hautement
préoccupée l'union européenne
la correspondance à moscou d'antoine
cléroux le ministre de la défense a fait
une annonce très importante alors qu'il
inspectait des troupes mobilisées sur la
péninsule de crimée se disant satisfaits
de leur capacité à défendre le pays
sergueï choïgou a annoncé la fin des
exercices militaires qui se déroulait
dans l'ouest et le sud du pays c'est à
dire à proximité de la frontière
ukrainienne
il a donc demandé à ce que les soldats
réintègrent leurs casernes
au cours des exercices les militaires
ont fait preuve d'un haut niveau de
formation professionnelle les
groupements les détachements et les
unités militaires ont respecté les
normes de mise en condition
opérationnelle du plus haut degré de
création de groupements de troupes et de
force de bonne exécution des missions
d'entraînement et de combat
j'estime que les objectifs de
l'inspection inopinés sont pleinement
atteint les forces armées ont démontré
leur capacité à assurer une défense
fiable du pays
par conséquent j'ai décidé de mettre fin
aux opérations de vérification dans les
districts militaire sud et ouest
cela ne veut pas dire pour autant que la
russie ne gardera pas un oeil sur les
exercices militaires de l'otan des
manoeuvres qui se dérouleront à sa
frontière immédiate
il faut continuer à surveiller la
situation dans les zones des exercices
défendre europe et être prêts à réagir
immédiatement en cas d'évolution
défavorable en retirant ses troupes de
cette région sous haute tension depuis
plusieurs semaines la russie envoie un
signal fort fait savoir de façon
concrète qu'elle ne menace personne
comme cela avait été précédemment dit et
répété cependant en retour
moscou compte bien suivre de très près
l'activité militaire de l'otan
littéralement sur le pas de sa porte